le monde sait ce cui des enfants va ça
va aujourd'hui on se retrouve de nouveau
sur une apps mal sur counter strike
source et ça pourrait tout ce que j'ai à
dire
vous faites un truc ou quoi la basilica
j'arrive à ses attentes il ya une
théorie qui dit que si on s'en fout on a
plus de chances de survivre à temps bien
pâle est bien là ce n'est rien au regard
garcelle la dialyse zenica si j'arrive
jusqu'à toi c'est que notre amour est
éternel natation le pilier personne
n'est pas du tout sauf s'il vous plaît
il paraît que ça augmente les chances de
survie dit vous montre rien j'arrête là
non et hop tu as vu le plaquage comme
par hasard au nom lorsque je peux s'est
perdue mi car il n'y a pas de soucis
mika et regardent leur ya pas de souci
non pas un pouce au smic à nos adieux
mais bassim sais plus quel âge tu en
train de rouler au lavage
nous avons connu un petit replay pour
hugo jules quel âge tu en prends devant
vous les hommes chez les plaines et
jérémy bas genre mais là je tenterai
voilà bon quelqu'un peut me plaire comme
non non non
nous inviterons d'expérience on ne peut
pas lutter oh c'est la cata mika
j'arrive en bas je suis là on a gagné
ego janin oui georges et à paris là deux
mètres de moi comme pas un stock de
[ __ ] du gobi un des gages aux [ __ ]
pour les mecs je veux rester en vie
jusqu'à la fin voilà c'est mon souhait
est vraiment j'aimerais vraiment qu'ils
se réalisent voilà c'est pas moi c'est
toi c'est certain c'est en tout cas
d'accord super je jamais encore une fois
le retour de gilbert music à daegu la
station je vais tomber rémois là je suis
désolé et j'étais handicapé du temps
doux quand j'étais petit et sabha sud
arrête arrête à toi toi tu as toi du
poker
voilà je ne bouge pas ça me tue pas ne
bougez pas au final c'est comme une
grosse merde j'ai appelé ben oui mais
j'étais objet de pas bougé pour la
détection
je suis revu sa banque bayernlb a entamé
sa marche pas ça marche ça arrête
je suis le vitrier même s'il n'y a pas
de doute mais engagée par contre c'est
vraiment les gars les gars se rapproche
très envie de cette manchette tatin
soldes allez moi mourir à d'autres comme
ça le courage d'aller jusqu'à toi tous
ensemble je vais mourir
e 3 e au palais sant palme en os mais
s'il respecte ses meilleurs amis un
style pur flammes
tu m'a touché
quand tu es ici d'auschwitz où est le
roi de mongo mais est ce que tu vas
prendre sur la gueule aussi j'avais
trois du monde bouge bouge de plus haut
mais voilà comment tu as pu rater ça non
mais [ __ ] [ __ ] couteau chacun sur un
bas et dernier bâtiment puis sont fait
tabasser accord jamais le corps chaka
chaka sur la voie
la scène que tu as fait c'est la bande
annonce du prochain mission en russie
ont coûté chacun à la loi s'attaque aux
bouquins mais cette chance avait sauté
attendais pas allez on les dit je te
revois les enfants au revoir on voit de
plus une secte alors pressé que ça vous
comprendrez pas en fait quand tu sautes
dans le trou du milieu sur cette map ça
t'amène dans un hélico que tu peux
contrôler certains récupèrent le court
je suis cuit pourquoi les coups de pied
oui c'est pas de bébé dedans pour faire
tomber de l'autre voilà comment toi là
où je suis là comme ça ne bouge pas à
temps bush pas besoin d'aller bien
bouger plus bougez plus tard en mai
moyen on voit bien les gars dégâts les
gars on va voir lucas bush
oui notamment la mafia ces légendes
dessus avant de mourir mais clés du
cochon fait l'écho comment ça je peux
pas je tente un truc les marchés c'était
spontané le truc non papa tu as dans ses
bras et la fin de vos maîtres et j'ai
regardé tartas et plus grosses équipes
c'est un tollé au survie
negash l'agencé déjà fin de cette
deuxième vidéo sur le mode ce match si
ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça me fait
vraiment plaisir je vois ce qui me
procure le monde avait pas cette fois
pis
m
[Musique]